Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
HI.
THAT IS JUST NASTY.
AT FunBites,
WE MAKE FOOD FUN.
WHY DON'T WE JUST LET THEM
STARVE?
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
BOO-YAH.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
GUESS WHAT TIME IT IS.
WHAT TIME IS IT?
IT'S DEAL TIME.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
LORI, HOW MANY PRODUCTS
HAVE YOU LICENSED?
DAYMOND!
LISTEN, SHE HAS NO ANSWER
'CAUSE IT'S ZERO.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I CAN SEE A MASSIVE MARKET SHARE
IN THE CLOWN MARKET.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'D LIKE YOU TO SAY YES
RIGHT NOW.
ACTUALLY, IT'S NOT TOO LATE
TO CHANGE YOUR MIND.
THAT IS SUCH A BAD IDEA.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I'M SUMAN.
I'M NISHES.
WE BOTH LIVE
IN MUKILTEO, WASHINGTON,
BUT WE WERE BORN AND RAISED
IN NEPAL.
I IMMIGRATED TO AMERICA
BECAUSE I WANTED TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION.
MY FATHER ALWAYS TAUGHT ME THAT
AMERICA IS LAND OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE WHO EARNED IT.
I SETTLED IN WASHINGTON STATE,
WHERE I MET NISHES.
SINCE WE WERE BOTH
FROM NEPAL,
WE BONDED REAL QUICK
AND BECAME REALLY GOOD FRIENDS.
[ TRADITIONAL
INDIAN MUSIC PLAYS ]
HOW'S IT GOING OUT THERE?
WHERE YOU AT?
I'M IN THE FOOTHILLS
OF THE HIMALAYAS.
SUJAN IS MY BROTHER AND THIRD
PARTNER OF OUR BUSINESS.
HE IS HANDLING MOST
OF THE PRODUCT IN NEPAL.
BACK IN THE DAY, OUR PEOPLE
CAME UP WITH THIS SNACK
MADE OUT OF YAK MILK.
80% OF PEOPLE IN NEPAL
EAT THESE SNACKS.
IT'S A HIGH SOURCE OF PROTEIN
FOR THEM.
I KNEW THIS COULD BE
OUR PATH TO SUCCESS,
AND WE GOT RIGHT TO WORK.
GOOD JOB, MAN.
WE'VE BEEN DOING
REALLY GOOD,
BUT WE HAVE POTENTIAL TO BE
A HUGE BUSINESS.
BUT FOR THAT,
WE NEED SHARKS.
WE GIVE 100% OF OUR TIME
AND ENERGY, BUT WE NEED HELP.
WE NEED SHARK TO TAKE
OUR BUSINESS TO NEXT LEVEL
AND MAKE OUR AMERICAN DREAM
COME TRUE.
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS ]
NAMASTE.
MY NAME
IS SUMAN SHRESTHA.
I AM
NISHES SHRESTHA.
AND I AM
SUJAN SHRESTHA.
AND WE COME ALL THE WAY
FROM THE HIMALAYAS.
OUR COMPANY
IS HIMALAYAN DOG CHEW,
AND WE ARE SEEKING $750,000
FOR 5% STAKE IN OUR COMPANY.
HOLY...
WOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'VE TAKEN
THIS AUTHENTIC CHEESE
EATEN BY THE PEOPLE
OF THE HIMALAYAS
AND TURNED IT INTO
A NUTRIENT-PACKED DOG TREAT.
AND DOGS LOVE OUR TREAT --
NOT ONLY DOGS --
DOG PARENTS LOVE IT, TOO,
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL NATURAL.
SHARKS, OUR CHEWS ARE MADE
WITH TRADITIONAL METHODS
WITH ONLY FOUR INGREDIENTS --
YAK AND COW MILK,
SALT, AND LIME JUICE.
THE MILK IS BOILED
AND COAGULATED INTO CHEESE,
WHICH IS THEN DRIED AND SMOKED
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS
INTO HARD, SMOKED CHEESE
LIKE THIS.
ONCE YOUR DOG CHEWS
THIS LARGE PIECE
INTO A SMALL PIECE
LIKE THIS,
SIMPLY MICROWAVE IT
FOR ABOUT 45 SECONDS TO A MINUTE
AND PUFF IT LIKE THIS,
INTO A CRUMBLY,
CRUNCHY CHEESE PUFF
SO THAT THERE IS
NO CHOKING HAZARD
AND NO WASTE AT ALL.
HIMALAYAN DOG CHEW IS THE BEST
TREAT OUT IN THE MARKET,
AND OUR SALES HAVE
BEEN INCREASING,
BUT NOW WE NEED
YOUR HELP
TO TAKE OUR COMPANY
AND OUR VENTURE
INTO THE NEXT LEVEL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO NOW
HAND OUT OUR SAMPLES.
IT'S FOR DOGS --
I JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR.
YES.
ALL RIGHT.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
DON'T TRY IT,
ROBERT.
THESE PACKAGES ARE ALREADY
OPENED FOR YOU A LITTLE BIT
SO THAT YOU CAN
TEAR IT OUT.
Herjavec:
SO -- SO, WAIT -- IN NEPAL,
IS THIS A SPECIAL CHEESE
THAT'S ONLY AVAILABLE THERE?
CURRENTLY,
I WOULD SAY YES.
THERE IS SOME AVAILABLE
IN INDIA, AS WELL,
BUT MOSTLY IN NEPAL.
AND IN NEPAL, IS IT FOR DOGS,
OR DO HUMANS EAT IT?
IT'S FOR HUMANS.
PIECES LIKE THIS,
WE CHEW THEM.
YOU DO?
REALLY?!
YES.
IS IT EXACTLY THE SAME?
SO IF WE STARTED CHEWING ON IT,
IT WOULD BE ALL RIGHT?
OH, YEAH,
YOU WOULD BE ALL RIGHT.
YEAH.
BUT WHAT WE DO IS,
WHEN WE BRING IT --
BRING IT TO THE U.S.,
WE PROCESS IT A LITTLE BIT
TO MAKE IT A LITTLE HARDER.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
WHAT ARE THE OTHER PRODUCTS?
WHAT'S THAT WHITE STUFF?
WE USE THAT SAME PUFFING
CHARACTER OF THAT CHEESE
AND PUT IT
IN A POPCORN BAG.
NOW, YOU PUT THIS POPCORN BAG
IN MICROWAVE.
FOR HUMANS OR DOGS?
FOR DOGS, OF COURSE.
DANG!
I WAS HUNGRY.
Cuban:
I WAS HOPING IT WAS...
AND THEN -- AND THEN
YOU PUT IT IN MICROWAVE.
IT POPS
JUST LIKE POPCORN BAG,
YOU OPEN IT UP --
CAN WE TRY IT?
AND THAT'S YAK CHEESE?
YES, IT'S GOOD.
OH, BRING IT ON.
I'M HUNGRY.
IT'S LITERALLY BLAND.
IT'S NO FLAVOR ON IT, THOUGH.
IT'S KIND OF COOL-LOOKING.
JUST EAT IT.
THAT IS
KIND OF COOL-LOOKING.
[ CRUNCHING ]
IT JUST DRIES
IN MOUTH REALLY FAST.
THAT'S NOT BAD, KIND OF,
AS A CHEESE, RIGHT?
OH, MY GOSH!
IT'S REALLY GOOD!
YEAH, YEAH.
TELL US
ABOUT YOUR NUMBERS.
UH, LAST YEAR, WE DID
$5.6 MILLION IN SALES.
OH, MY GOD!
DANG!
WHOA!
THAT'S A LOT OF CHEW.
THAT'S A LOT OF CHEESE.
WE SOLD A LITTLE BIT OVER
A-A MILLION, UH, PACKAGES.
WHERE ARE YOU
SELLING THESE?
WHERE?
DIRECTLY, WE SELL IT IN
LOT OF DIFFERENT INDEPENDENT
PET-SPECIALTY RETAILERS.
WE ARE
IN ABOUT 6,000 STORES.
SO, WHY ARE YOU HERE?
YOU HAVE $5.6 MILLION IN SALES,
AND YOU'RE PROBABLY MAKING
MORE THAN A MILLION DOLLARS
IN PROFIT, RIGHT?
YES, WE ARE.
YOU'RE KILLIN' IT.
WE'RE HERE
FOR PARTNERSHIP.
YOU CAN BRING VALUE
INTO OUR COMPANY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THREE OF US,
WE ARE REALLY HARDWORKING
IMMIGRANTS FROM NEPAL,
BUT W-WE'RE LOOKING AT SHARKS
IN THE FRONT,
AND, UH, YOU KNOW, UH, LORI, UH,
UH, SHE'S A RETAIL GODDESS.
UH, MR. WONDERFUL --
NOW YOU'RE JUST KISSING UP.
UM, I JUST DON'T SEE --
THAT DOESN'T HURT.
I'M NEXT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GUYS, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE SEEN EVERYTHING.
WE'VE SEEN EVERY KIND
OF DOG TREAT, EVERY KIND OF --
Cuban: YEAH, YOU'RE NOT
THE FIRST COMPANY
TO WALK IN HERE
WITH AN ORGANIC DOG TREAT.
BUT WE'VE NEVER SEEN SOMEBODY
DO $5.6 MILLION IN THIS.
WHAT IS THE SECRET SAUCE?
THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS
FOR THAT.
FIRST, WE, UH -- WE HAD AN,
UH, STRICT FINANCIAL APPROACH.
WE DID NOT TAKE ANY PROFITS
INTO OUR POCKETS.
WE JUST KEPT ON
PUTTING IT BACK.
DID YOU RAISE A LOT OF MONEY
AT -- AT THE BEGINNING?
WE STARTED WITH $2,000.
WHEN THESE GUYS STARTED --
WANTED TO START
THIS BUSINESS --
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
I'M ABOUT TO ASK YOU
FOR A JOB.
I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU'RE HERE.
O'Leary:
LET'S GO BACK TO VALUATION --
$15 MILLION, 3 TIMES SALES.
A LITTLE AGGRESSIVE FOR
THE PET-TREAT INDUSTRY, MAYBE?
WE VALUED OUR COMPANY
AT $15 MILLION
IS BECAUSE OF OUR PROJECTION
THIS YEAR,
AS WELL AS WE HAVE THE --
WHAT'S YOUR PROJECTION?
WHAT IS YOUR PROJECTION
FOR THIS YEAR?
UH, THIS YEAR, WE'RE GONNA
DO AT LEAST $8 MILLION.
WHAT DO YOU NEED
THE $750,000 FOR?
WELL, $750,000 --
WE -- WE PLAN TO KEEP
HALF OF IT
'CAUSE WE'VE NEVER TAKEN
DIVIDENDS.
AND WE JUST STARTED TAKING
SALARIES LAST YEAR.
YOU MEAN YOU JUST
WANT TO TAKE MY MONEY
AND GIVE IT TO YOURSELF?
REALLY?
Cuban:
I ADMIRE THE HONESTY,
BUT THAT'S [Chuckling] SUCH
A BAD THING TO SAY TO THEM.
GUYS, YEAH, I THINK, UH -- LOOK,
YOU GET CREDIT FOR BEING HONEST,
BUT THE REALITY IS, YOU HAVE
THE CASH FLOW TO PAY YOURSELF.
YOU COULD GO TO THE BANK AND
BORROW AGAINST YOUR CASH FLOW.
I'M NOT BUYING
THAT YOU NEED US.
THIS IS A GREAT
P.R. OPPORTUNITY.
YOU'RE SMART FOR TRYING
TO DO IT, BUT YOU DON'T NEED US.
I'M OUT.
GUYS, RATHER THAN DEBATE
THE MERITS
OR THE REASON YOU'RE HERE,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'M NOT GONNA PUT IN $750,000
FOR EQUITY.
I'M GONNA MAKE IT DEBT.
BUT YOU KNOW,
BEFORE I GET DETAILED,
LET'S SEE WHO'S REALLY
INTERESTED
TO SEE
WHO I'M COMPETING WITH.
WHO'S IN ON THIS THING?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND [Chuckling]
HOW YOU GUYS
HAVE DONE SO MUCH MONEY WORTH
OF THIS DOG TREAT.
DOGS LIKE IT.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST MIND--
MIND-BLOWING TO ME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT,
SO I'LL SPARE YOU
A LONG EXPLANATION,
AND I'LL JUST TELL YOU
I'M OUT.
DAYMOND, ARE YOU
INTERESTED OR NOT?
I'M NOT INTERESTED
AT THE MOMENT.
I'M OUT.
Cuban:
LOOK, I'M INTERESTED.
I'M NOT INTERESTED
AT A $15 MILLION VALUE,
BUT I'M INTERESTED.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME THROW
AN OFFER OUT THERE.
WE'LL SEE IF OTHERS WANT TO JOIN
OR THEY WANT TO COMPETE.
BUT THEY'RE NOT WORTH
$8 MILLION TO ME, KEVIN.
I DIDN'T --
I AGREE. SO HANG ON.
HANG ON, ROBERT.
I THINK THEY'RE WORTH
$6 MILLION.
LET ME WORK
SOMETHING HERE.
HERE'S THE THING --
IT'S NOT ONLY
ABOUT THIS PRODUCT.
YOU WANT TO HEAR AN OFFER,
OR YOU WANT TO TALK?
ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE WORTH $15 MILLION,
AND I THINK ALL THE SHARKS
ARE IN THE SAME BOAT ON THAT,
BUT I LIKE THE FACT
THAT IT HAS SALES.
SO, YOU KNOW,
I'M NOT GONNA LET YOU
TAKE OUR CASH
OUT OF THE BUSINESS.
NO BANK'S
GONNA LET YOU DO IT.
I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO,
BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEND
THE $750,000
TOWARDS BUILDING CAPACITY,
SO I'M GONNA LEND YOU
$750,000 AT 10%.
IT'LL BE OUT THERE
FOR 36 MONTHS -- 3 YEARS --
AND YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME
5% EQUITY
BECAUSE YOU WANT A SHARK
ON YOUR TEAM.
SO, THIS IS CALLED
VENTURE DEBT.
YOUR COMPANY
IS IDEAL FOR IT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TO AGREE
ON VALUATION, ALL RIGHT?
Herjavec: KEVIN, I LIKE
YOUR DEAL, BUT 5% ISN'T ENOUGH.
CAN I COME IN WITH YOU,
AND WE GET 10%?
DONE.
OKAY.
YOU GET TWO SHARKS.
IF YOUR OFFER STANDS,
CAN WE GO BACK
AND TALK AND COME BACK
REALLY QUICK?
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU LEAVE THE CARPET.
GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD.
IT'S NOT THE CASH HERE --
WE WANT THE RELATIONSHIP,
BUT THE EQUITY IS TOO HIGH --
10% WITH NO MONEY.
PUT $250,000, YOU MAKE 10%
ON YOUR MONEY FOR 36 MONTHS.
THAT'S FANTASTIC.
36 MONTHS --
Greiner:
AND THEN 5% EQUITY.
AND THEN THAT'S --
10%, 10%.
10% EQUITY.
NO, NO,
WE NEED 5% EACH.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT --
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
OH, THAT WOULD BE 15--
BECAUSE THEY LEFT THE TANK,
THEY GOT SCREWED.
WELCOME BACK, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
SO, WHAT HAPPENS IN THE TANK
WHEN PEOPLE LEAVE THE CARPET
IS THE WATERS SWIRL.
YOU KNOW.
YOU'VE SEEN THE SHOW.
LORI EXPRESSED INTEREST
IN IT.
THAT MEANS
YOU GET 3 SHARKS,
AND NOW WE'RE ASKING
FOR 15% EQUITY.
WHEN YOU HAVE THREE SHARKS
IN A COMPANY LIKE THIS,
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
CAN HAPPEN.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE A SHERPA
WHEN YOU'RE IN BUSINESS, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHS ]
THEY DEFINITELY WILL.
YOU GOT THREE SHERPAS!
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN, LORI, AND ROBERT
HAVE ONE OFFER ON THE TABLE --
$750,000 AS A LOAN
FOR 15% EQUITY OF THE HIMALAYAN
DOG CHEW COMPANY.
WHEN YOU HAVE THREE SHARKS
IN A COMPANY LIKE THIS,
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
CAN HAPPEN.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
[ SPEAKING INDISTINCTLY ]
YEAH, WE HAVE TO HUMBLY --
HUMBLY DECLINE THAT.
Greiner: WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM
WITH THE DEAL?
YOU DON'T LIKE
THAT IT'S A DEBT DEAL?
EXACTLY. WE -- WE HAVE A MILLION
DOLLARS IN LINE OF CREDIT,
WHICH IS, UH -- WE HAVE --
WE DON'T EVEN USE IT.
SO WHY DON'T YOU ASK US
TO LOWER THE INTEREST RATE?
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY DON'T NEED IT.
MARK, WHY ARE YOU MAKING
NOISE OVER THERE?
WHY WOULD THEY GIVE UP EQUITY
WHEN THEY GET THE LOAN FOR FREE?
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
SEE THEM BE STUPID.
COME ON! YOU DON'T EVEN WANT TO
GIVE THEM A DIME!
GOSH.
CAN WE DO $750,000
FOR 10%?
BUT IS IT DEBT,
OR IS IT EQUITY?
STRAIGHT EQUITY.
I'M NOT INTERESTED
IN THAT DEAL.
YEAH, I WANT TO DO
THE DEBT, GUYS.
THEY CUT THEIR VALUATION
IN HALF, GUYS.
HEY, IT'S -- I'M NOT --
MARK, THEN WHY DON'T YOU
GET BACK IN?
THEY WENT FROM 5% TO 10%.
WHY DON'T YOU DO
THAT DEAL?
I'M JUST ARBITRATING --
YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS ARE
ARGUING ABOUT SEMANTICS.
THAT'S VERY KIND OF YOU.
BUT AT THIS POINT,
IT'S NOT USEFUL.
YEAH, WE'VE ALREADY
CUT DOWN OUR VALUATION,
LIKE WHAT MARK SAID,
TO HALF OF IT.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOUR VALUE
IS WHEN YOU'RE GETTING DEBT.
W-WE CAN GIVE YOU A --
WE CAN DO A-A BIGGER PERCENTAGE
OF EQUITY FOR MORE MONEY --
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING LIKE
MAYBE 20% FOR $1.5 MILLION?
YOU KNOW, HONESTLY,
I WENT IN
BECAUSE KEVIN AND ROBERT
CONVINCED ME
WITH THE ORIGINAL OFFER.
BUT I DON'T LIKE THE COUNTER,
SO I'M OUT.
IF I HAD ANY INTEREST IN BEING
IN THE DOG-CHEW BUSINESS,
YOU'RE MAKING A GOOD OFFER.
MARK, IF IT'S SO GREAT,
WHY DON'T YOU TAKE IT?
I DON'T WANT TO BE
IN THE DOG-CHEW BUSINESS.
THIS IS
SO FRUSTRATING.
YOU GUYS ARE BEING CRAZY.
MARK'S BECOMING LIKE
THE NARRATOR OF THE SHARK TANK.
WE HAD A LOT OF NOISE
OUT OF MR. CUBAN.
HE'S GOOD AT MAKING NOISE, BUT
HE WOULDN'T WRITE YOU A CHECK.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
YES, FOR THE EQUITY.
UH, NO FOR THE LOAN.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
ARE INTERESTED, ARE WE?
AW. I'M OUT.
I'LL DO THE $750,000
ON MY OWN FOR 15%.
THAT'S ONE-THIRD
OF WHAT...
[ SCOFFS ]
THAT'S ALMOST LIKE ONE-THIRD
OF WHAT --
YOU WANTED
A STRAIGHT EQUITY DEAL.
[ SPEAKING INDISTINCTLY ]
WELL, THE TEAM SAYS NO
TO THAT DEAL, ROBERT.
I'M OUT.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
NAMASTE.
WELL, WE TRIED.
WE USED...
IT'S TOO MUCH.
BY THE TIME THEY GOT
TO THE LAST OFFER,
THAT WAS A GOOD DEAL
FROM THEM.
MARK, YOU KEEP
DOING GOOD DEALS.
I'LL DO SPECTACULAR DEALS.
THANK YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE DIDN'T WANT TO,
UH, DEVALUE OUR COMPANY
THE WAY THE SHARKS
WANTED TO OFFER.
UH, FROM THIS DAY
ON FORWARD,
WE JUST HAVE TO WORK
A LITTLE BIT HARDER --
UM, ACTUALLY HARDER
THAN EVER BEFORE --
AND PROVE TO THE SHARKS THAT WE
WERE CAPABLE OF THAT VALUATION.
Narrator: IN SEASON FOUR,
NEIL, DENNIS, AND PETE
LANDED A DEAL WITH
ROBERT HERJAVEC AND MARK CUBAN
FOR THEIR HIGH-PROTEIN
NUT-BUTTER COMPANY,
NUTS 'N MORE.
ROBERT,
WHAT'S YOUR FEELINGS?
I'LL GO DOWN TO MARK'S 35%.
YOU GUYS GOT A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
GOT IT.
LET'S SEE
HOW THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Cameron: HA HA!
THERE IT IS.
IN THE TWO YEARS
SINCE WE'VE MADE A DEAL
WITH MARK AND ROBERT,
WE'VE SEEN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF GROWTH.
Cuban: HEY, GUYS.
HEY, MARK.
WELCOME TO GNC
AND WELCOME TO PITTSBURGH.
THANK YOU.
HEY, IT'S GREAT
TO BE HOME.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
TODAY WE'RE MEETING
WITH MIKE ARCHBOLD,
THE C.E.O. OF GNC,
AND I HAVE A FEELING THERE'S A
BIG ANNOUNCEMENT COMING OUR WAY.
AND HOW'S SALES
BEEN GOING, MIKE?
IT SOLD SO WELL, WE WOUND UP
EXPANDING IT TO 2,000 STORES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
WOW.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THAT'S AWESOME.
Iannotti: OVER THE PAST YEAR,
WE'VE DONE VERY WELL
WITH OUR PEANUT
PROTEIN SPREADS.
NOW WE'RE EXPANDING
INTO OUR ALMOND WHEY-INFUSED
PROTEIN POWDER.
AS PART OF OUR COMMITMENT
TO NUTS 'N MORE,
WE'RE PREPARED TO ROLL IT OUT
WITH 4,000 STORES
ACROSS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY,
IN EVER SINGLE GNC STORE.
THAT'S AMAZING.
WOW!
MAN, THANK YOU, MIKE.
THAT'S AWESOME.
Cameron: WHEN WE PITCHED,
WE ONLY HAD $100,000 IN SALES.
JUST TWO YEARS
AFTER MAKING THE DEAL,
WE HAVE $6 MILLION
IN SALES.
NOW, WITH THIS EXPANSION
WITH GNC,
WE THINK OUR SALES
CAN REACH $20 MILLION.
AND WE'RE GONNA
DRINK TO IT, TOO.
LET'S DRINK TO THAT.
OH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND YOU PUT MY FAVORITE VODKA
IN HERE, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WORKING WITH MARK AND ROBERT
HAS BEEN AMAZING.
THEY'VE OPENED UP DOORS
WE NEVER THOUGHT IMAGINABLE.
Cuban: GOOD JOB, GUYS.
WE'RE JUST THREE NORMAL GUYS
FROM RHODE ISLAND WITH A DREAM,
AND THIS GAVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY MAKE IT COME TRUE.
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE A WOMAN'S MAKEUP
SHOULD MAKE A BOLD STATEMENT.
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS ]
HI.
I'M MELISSA BUTLER.
AND I'M ROSCO SPEARS.
Both: AND WE LIVE
IN BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
OUR COMPANY
IS THE LIP BAR,
AND WE'RE SEEKING
$125,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR BRAND.
THE LIP BAR WAS FOUNDED
OUT OF MY FRUSTRATION
WITH THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY.
I MEAN, COME ON.
WHY DO LIPSTICKS ONLY COME
IN REDS, PINKS, AND NUDES?
FURTHERMORE,
WHY IS IT FILLED
WITH SO MANY UNNECESSARY
CHEMICALS?
I REFUSED TO ACCEPT
THE STANDARD OF BEAUTY
THAT WAS BEING GIVEN TO ME,
AND THE LIP BAR WAS BORN.
OUR FOCUS IS SELF-EXPRESSIVE
AND RESPONSIBLY MADE COSMETICS.
WE OFFER
A WIDE RANGE OF HUES,
EVERYTHING FROM YOUR SPICY REDS
TO CASUAL NUDES
TO NEON PURPLES,
AND EVEN ELECTRIC BLUES.
IN ADDITION TO
OUR AWESOME COLOR RANGE,
ALL OF OUR LIPSTICKS CONTAIN
ORGANIC, FAIR TRADE SHEA BUTTER,
ORGANIC CASTOR
AND AVOCADO OILS.
WE NEVER USE PARABENS.
WE'RE VEGAN AND CRUELTY-FREE.
NOW, WHICH OF YOU SHARKS
ARE GONNA PUCKER UP
AND INVEST
IN THE LIP BAR?
CAN WE GET SAMPLES?
ABSOLUTELY.
YES.
LORI, WE WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO COME
AND SWIPE SOME
ON YOUR HAND.
SO, YOU GUYS ARE ACTUALLY
A LIPSTICK LINE,
NOT A BAR LIKE HAIR BAR
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WE'RE A LIPSTICK LINE,
BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY THEMATIC.
SO ALL OF THE LIPSTICKS ARE
NAMED AFTER POPULAR COCKTAILS
BECAUSE WE'RE FUN,
WE'RE YOUNG, WE'RE FREE,
AND WE WANT TO ENCOMPASS
THE ESSENCE OF A BAR.
IT'S FULL OF SHEA BUTTER.
IS THIS WHAT YOU'RE WEARING?
YES. THAT'S NATURAL LIP--
SO, IT'S VERY CREAMY,
AND IT'S VERY SMOOTH.
YES, IT'S FULL
OF SHEA BUTTER.
I CAN TELL THAT. YEAH.
YES.
THANK YOU
FOR TRYING IT.
I AM TAKING MINE WITH ME.
YES, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU PUT
THE BLUE ONE ON HER?
[ LAUGHTER ]
LIPSTICK,
BEAUTY INDUSTRY --
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR
BUSINESS.
YES.
HUGE.
YEP.
MANY BIG PLAYERS
WITH HUGE BRANDS
SPEND HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
A QUARTER ADVERTISING THEM.
THEY OWN
THE RETAIL SHELF SPACE.
IF THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD
SELL MORE LIPSTICK
WITH BLUE AND GREEN
AND WHATEVER OTHER COLORS
YOU'VE DREAMT UP,
DON'T YOU THINK
THEY'D DO THAT?
BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT IT'S ALL VERY SATURATED,
IT'S ALSO
ABOUT THE MESSAGING.
WHAT'S THE MESSAGING?
OUR MESSAGING
IS EMPOWERMENT.
SO, WE BELIEVE THAT A WOMAN
CAN BE WHOEVER THEY WANT TO BE.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE WITHIN
THIS COOKIE-CUTTER BOX
OF HAVING TO DO WHAT
THE INDUSTRY TELLS US.
HOW DO YOU SHARE
THE EMPOWERMENT MESSAGE?
YEAH, WHERE'S THAT MESSAGE
ON YOUR BRAND?
YEAH, BECAUSE LIPS
ON A COCKTAIL GLASS --
I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT SHARES EMPOWERMENT.
WE SHARE THE EMPOWERMENT
OF WOMEN
THROUGH
OUR WIDE COLORINGS,
AND IT'S A FORM OF --
WELL, THE -- THE PROOF
IS IN THE SALES.
RIGHT.
ARE YOU MAKING
ANY MONEY?
SO FAR, WE'VE MADE $107,000
SINCE INCEPTION.
AND THAT'S ALL BEEN
JUST FROM OUR WEBSITE.
SINCE WHEN IS THAT?
HOW LONG HAS THAT BEEN?
TWO YEARS.
WHAT DID YOU DO
THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD
IN THE LAST MONTH?
LAST 12--
IN THE LAST MONTH,
WE'VE SOLD $8,000 WORTH.
WHERE ARE YOU MAKING
THESE LIPSTICKS?
I ACTUALLY MAKE THEM
BY HAND MYSELF.
YOU MAKE THEM BY HAND?
YES.
AT -- AT -- AT HOME?
SO I DIDN'T HAVE --
YES.
BUT HOW MUCH I--
HOW MUCH IS EACH UNIT
COSTING YOU TO MAKE,
AND WHAT DO YOU
SELL IT FOR?
WHEN I MAKE IT, IT'S $3.
WE SELL IT FOR $20.
Greiner:
GREAT MARGINS.
IT'S SUPER-ADMIRABLE YOU'RE
MAKING IT OUT OF YOUR HOME...
Herjavec:
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
...AND YOU KNOW HOW
TO DO THAT
AND PACK IT
INTO THIS PRETTY CASE.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR WOMEN OF ALL
THESE DIFFERENT COMPLEXIONS
AND UNDERTONES TO FIND COLORS
THAT ARE PERFECT FOR THEM.
WE DECIDED TO CREATE
THIS APP
WHERE CUSTOMERS
CAN EASILY LOG ON,
CREATE THEIR OWN CUSTOM COLOR
FROM THESE 10 SHADES.
HOW MUCH DO I PAY YOU
FOR IT?
$32.
THIS IS
A NEW INNOVATION.
I CAN SEE A MASSIVE MARKET SHARE
IN THE CLOWN MARKET.
[ LAUGHS ]
KEVIN!
YOU GUYS
ARE BRIGHT WOMEN,
AND YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
VERY INDUSTRIOUS.
BUT BEING A WOMAN,
ONE OF THE HARD THINGS FOR ME
WITH COSMETICS
AND SHOPPING ONLINE
IS IT'S SO HARD FOR THE STORE
ONLINE TO CONVEY TO ME
WHAT THAT COLOR IS
REALLY GONNA TURN OUT LIKE
WHEN I GET IT HOME.
YOU'RE SAYING WOMEN WANT TO
SEE IT AND TOUCH IT.
WELL, IT'S JUST HARD TO
TRANSLATE IT, YOU KNOW?
LIKE, YOU LOOK,
AND YOU SEE A CERTAIN PINK,
AND THEN IT C-- YOU KNOW,
YOUR SCREEN IS BRIGHTER
OR YOUR SCREEN
IS LESS BRIGHT.
YOU KNOW, IT NEVER COMES
ACROSS THE EXACT WAY.
OH.
SO WHEN YOU GET IT HOME,
IT'S A GUESSING GAME.
Herjavec: ROSCO, THE BRAND
SENDS ME A MIXED MESSAGE.
I'M NOT SURE I WOULD WANT
MY DAUGHTER,
UH, PICKING UP LIPSTICK
WITH A MARTINI GLASS
AND, UH, VERY SENSUAL LIPS
ON IT IN RED...
OKAY.
...WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO SELL
THE IDEA OF MULTIPLE COLORS.
I-I'M NOT BUYING
INTO THE BRAND.
I'M OUT.
SO, ONE OF OUR MAIN ISSUES
IS DISTRIBUTION.
WE'VE TALKED TO A LOT
OF LARGE RETAILERS.
AND THE BEAUTY BUYERS, THEY
ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE PRODUCT.
AND BECAUSE WE'VE HAD THIS ISSUE
WITH DISTRIBUTION,
INSTEAD OF SITTING
ON OUR BUTTS, WAITING ON,
YOU KNOW, A RETAILER
TO PICK US UP, WE DECIDED TO --
WE CAME UP WITH
THE INNOVATIVE IDEA
TO BUILD
A LIP BAR MOBILE.
A WHAT?
UGH.
HAVE YOU BUILT THIS?
Butler:
IT'S IN THE PROCESS.
IT'S ACTUALLY BEING CONVERTED
IN DETROIT RIGHT NOW.
OH, THAT IS
SUCH A BAD IDEA.
SO, ROSCO,
AREN'T YOU WORRIED,
IF YOU WALKED INTO A BAR
WITH THAT COLOR LIP,
SOMEBODY WOULD TRY
TO RESUSCITATE YOU?
[ LAUGHTER ]
NO.
WHEN I WALK INTO THE BAR
OR INTO THE MALL
OR ANYWHERE
WITH THIS COLOR LIP,
EVERYONE
IS VERY INQUISITIVE.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHERE
I GOT IT FROM, WHO MADE IT,
WHERE DID I GET
THIS CRAZY SHADE,
AND THAT JUST DRIVES
SALES.
THE CHANCES THAT THIS IS
A BUSINESS ARE PRACTICALLY ZERO
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
GET SHARE.
IF -- IF ANYBODY THOUGHT
YOU COULD SELL PURPLE OR GREEN
LIPSTICK, THEY'D DO IT.
THEY ALREADY HAVE
THE SHELF SPACE.
THEY'D JUST ADD
ANOTHER COLOR.
AND THEY WOULD CRUSH YOU
LIKE THE COLORFUL COCKROACHES
YOU ARE.
YOU ONLY HAVE
SO MANY MINUTES ON EARTH.
DON'T WASTE THEM
TRYING TO SELL LIPSTICK.
I'M OUT.
DAYMOND.
WE KNOW
THAT YOUR EXPERTISE
COULD HELP US
CATAPULT THIS.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO CREATE
ANYTHING NEW IN THIS WORLD.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIPSTICK.
I'M OUT.
IF YOU'RE WALKING PAST
A COUNTER,
AND THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT BRANDS,
EVEN THE LIPS
ON THE MARTINI GLASS ARE RED.
MM-HMM.
IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU HAVE CRAZY COLORS.
LOOK, I GET THAT IF SOMEBODY
WEARS A SHOCKING LIPSTICK
THAT MAKES THEM STAND OUT,
THAT'S A SIGN OF CONFIDENCE.
YES.
YOU KNOW?
THEY'RE WILLING TO SAY,
"I KNOW PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT ME.
I DON'T CARE. THIS IS WHO I AM."
THAT'S GREAT.
BUT YOU KIND OF WENT
COCKTAIL-THEMATIC,
WHICH REALLY
ISN'T THE SAME THING
AS BEING
OVER-THE-TOP CONFIDENT.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S ONLY ONE SHARK
LEFT -- LORI.
Greiner: LISTEN, YOU GUYS.
I USED TO SELL MAKEUP.
MAKEUP IS A GREAT THING TO SELL
FOR ONE REASON --
IT HAS GREAT MARGINS.
ON THE FLIP SIDE, IT'S ONE
OF THE HARDEST THINGS TO SELL
BECAUSE IT HAS SUCH
INCREDIBLE COMPETITION.
I'M OUT.
SEE YOU GUYS.
SO LONG.
THANK YOU.
Speers: WE'RE A LITTLE SAD,
A LITTLE HEARTBROKEN
BECAUSE
WE BUILT THIS BABY
AND THEY KIND OF, LIKE,
JUST SHOT IT DOWN.
BUT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP GOING,
AND WE'RE GONNA BE
A MAJOR BRAND,
AND THEY'LL SEE US,
AND THEY'LL BE PROUD OF US.
ROWR!
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A PRODUCT
THAT'S BUILT NOT TO SPILL.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OH, NO.
THAT IS JUST NASTY.
UGH.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT IS NOT ATTRACTIVE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S KEVIN WALTERMIRE.
I'M HERE TO ASK $50,000
FOR A 15% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY COMPANY, BeverageBoy.
ENVISION A SCENARIO
WE'VE ALL SEEN BEFORE --
A GUY ENJOYING HIMSELF,
RELAXING IN A POOL,
HAVING THE TIME OF HIS LIFE --
UNTIL HE GETS DISTRACTED...
OH!
...AND SPILLS HIS --
OH, NO!
STOP THE MADNESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND SPILLS HIS DRINK
ALL OVER HIMSELF,
JUST RUINING HIS DAY.
THANKFULLY, THE BevBoy IS HERE
TO SAVE THE DAY.
THANK GOODNESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE BevBoy WILL MIRACULOUSLY
FLOAT IN WATER WITHOUT SPILLING.
THINK OF IT AS YOUR VERY OWN
PERSONAL FLOATING SIDEKICK.
PEOPLE WILL TAKE NOTICE
THAT YOU'RE DIFFERENT
AT THE POOL PARTY.
YOU TAKE THINGS
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
IF THEIR MOTTO
IS "WORK HARD, PLAY HARD,"
YOUR MOTTO IS
"WORK HARD, PLAY HARDER."
BOO-YAH.
HELP ME SAVE THE DAY.
INVEST IN BeverageBoy
AND FLOAT WITH ME.
KEVIN, CAN WE SEE THEM?
I'D LOVE TO SHOW YOU
SOME SAMPLES.
AND CAN LORI GET IN THE HOT TUB
WITH YOUR FRIEND?
OF COURSE.
THE MORE, THE MERRIER.
IT'S A PARTY.
GO, LORI.
AND I'LL EXPLAIN
HOW IT WORKS TO YOU.
THE WEIGHTED EXTENSION GIVES IT
A CENTER OF GRAVITY,
SO NO MATTER IF IT BOBS
LEFT OR RIGHT
OR IF IT RIDES OVER A WAVE,
IT ALWAYS COMES BACK TO CENTER.
Greiner:
PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
THAT'S THE PHYSICS OF IT.
DID YOU CREATE
THIS YOURSELF?
PRETTY COOL.
YOU KNOW WHAT? IT WAS ACTUALLY
A GREAT COLLEGE POOL PARTY.
WE'RE ALL HANGING OUT,
AND A FRIEND OF OURS
FELL OFF OF A RAFT.
AND I JUST HAD A MOMENT
AND WAS LIKE, "LOOK,
IF WE HAVE RAFTS, WHY DON'T
OUR DRINKS HAVE RAFTS?"
WHERE ARE YOU SELLING IT?
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
I'VE SOLD, UH, 2,500 UNITS,
SO ABOUT $10,500 IN REVENUE.
AND I'M IN STORES
FROM MASSACHUSETTS TO TEXAS.
OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME,
KEVIN?
UH, THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
OH, YOU --
THIS IS BRAND-NEW.
YES.
IS THIS LIKE THE MODERN-DAY'S
MAN VERSION OF A TASTEVIN?
[ Laughing ] TASTEVIN!
Herjavec: A WHAT?
INTERESTING, DAYMOND.
THE CHEVALIERS DU TASTEVIN.
LOOK AT THIS.
OH, MY GOD.
THEY MAY LITIGATE.
HE'S GOING,
"WHAT IS THAT?"
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THAT IS.
O'Leary: SO, KEVIN...
[ LAUGHTER ]
...THE TASTEVIN
IS A DEVICE
THAT'S USED TO SIP
A VERY BEAUTIFUL WINE
FROM THE BURGUNDY REGION
OF FRANCE.
I'M GLAD
YOU MENTIONED THAT.
"OH, BUT THERE'S MORE."
I'VE HEARD ABOUT YOU
AND YOUR WINE,
SO WE'LL POUR YOU
ONE OF YOUR --
MAYBE A FINE BORDEAUX
FOR YOU.
YEAH.
AND WE'RE JUST GONNA
DROP IT IN WATER,
AND NOW YOU CAN PARTY,
TOO, MR. WONDERFUL.
LOOK AT THAT.
I WILL TELL THE CONFRéRIE.
[ LAUGHS ]
Greiner:
SO, WHAT DOES THIS COST,
AND WHAT DOES IT COST
TO MAKE?
IT COSTS ME ABOUT $2.
I WHOLESALE IT AT $5.
MY RETAILERS RETAIL IT
AT $9.99.
WHY AREN'T THE COLLEGE PEOPLE
ON BOARD WITH THIS?
WHY ISN'T IT TAKING OFF
A LITTLE BIT MORE?
YOU KNOW, I ACTUALLY THINK
IT'S MY FAILURE
TO GET IT OUT
IN FRONT OF THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
KEVIN, THAT'S WHERE
I'M GOING.
HAVE YOU DONE TRADE SHOWS?
I HAVE.
AND -- AND
SO WHAT HAPPENED?
I WENT TO THE, UH,
PROMOTIONAL-PRODUCTS SHOW
IN CHICAGO
A FEW MONTHS AGO --
SOLD OUT OF EVERY UNIT
I TOOK THERE.
YEAH, BUT DID YOU -- DID YOU
GET ANY ORDERS IN STORES?
SO WHAT STORES
GAVE YOU ORDERS?
ACTUALLY, SO, I DIDN'T BRING
ANY ORDER FORMS TO THOSE SHOWS.
IT WAS JUST AN EXCHANGE
OF INFORMATION.
HOW COULD YOU NOT BRING
AN ORDER FORM TO A TRADE SHOW?
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
A MENTOR OF MINE TOLD ME
IT WAS MORE ABOUT GETTING
THE PRODUCT OUT THERE.
IT'S A TRADE SHOW.
BUT I TAKE THEIR BUSINESS
INFORMATION --
YOU KNOW WHAT, KEVIN?
ANYBODY WHO REFUSES
TO TAKE AN ORDER FORM
TO A TRADE SHOW...
I'M OUT.
WHOA!
HOW COULD YOU NOT TAKE
AN ORDER --
THAT'S NOT LIKE NOT HAVING A PEN
WHEN YOU GO TO CLOSE THE DEAL.
YOU KNOW, WE SEE
ALL KINDS OF CRAZY THINGS.
O'Leary: I THINK
YOU'RE SEEING ONE RIGHT NOW.
I N--
I NEVER JUDGE THINGS.
I DO.
THEY'RE -- THEY'RE POO-POO
ON A STICK YOU GIVE AWAY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE MADE A MISTAKE
AND HAVE DROPPED THEIR CAN,
THEIR CUP IN THE WATER?
AND I KNOW IT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU LAUGH AT,
AND YOU THINK IT'S POO-POO,
BUT WHEN YOU WATCH IT,
IT WORKS,
AND IT'S HILARIOUS.
PEOPLE ENJOY USING IT.
ALL RIGHT, KEVIN,
I'VE BEEN LISTENING,
AND NOW I'M SAYING THIS --
YOUR NAME IS KEVIN,
MY NAME IS KEVIN --
I'M OFFICIALLY STRIPPING YOU
OF YOUR NAME
BECAUSE THIS IDEA
IS SO BAD.
IT IS SO GOOD.
IT IS SO BAD.
YOU DO NOT DESERVE
THE NAME KEVIN.
YOU ARE NOW CALLED "ZONK."
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M SORRY, MAN. I AM OUT.
THIS SUCKS.
BY THE WAY, ZONK,
IF YOU DON'T GET A DEAL,
YOU'RE LEAVING
WITH THE ZONK NAME.
I'M NOT LEAVING WITH THE NAME,
BUT THANK YOU.
LOOK, KEVIN,
THE ONLY THING THAT'S MISSING
FROM YOUR ENTIRE PRESENTATION
IS YOU COME OUT,
WE ALL LAUGH AT YOU,
AND THEN YOU SAY,
"BUT I HAVE HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES,"
AND WE ALL GO, "WOW!"
AND THEN YOU GET A DEAL.
I JUST STARTED.
FOR SOME REASON,
IT'S NOT FLYING OFF THE SHELF.
I'M OUT.
OKAY, ZONK,
THERE'S ONLY TWO SHARKS LEFT.
LORI, ARE YOU
GONNA SAVE HIM?
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO JUDGE
HOW MANY PEOPLE
WANT A FLOATING BEER HOLDER.
ZONK-A-TRON.
A ZONK-A-TRON.
I DON'T -- I DON'T KNOW.
THIS IS A BevBoy,
AND I'M TELLING YOU,
WITH YOUR CAPABILITIES,
LORI,
IF YOU PUT THIS ON QVC
AND PEOPLE ACTUALLY SEE IT,
PEOPLE WILL LOVE IT.
LORI, IS THERE
A QVC CUSTOMER --
I DON'T KNOW --
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
A BETTER QVC PRODUCT.
I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS IS A QVC.
Waltermire:
I THINK IT IS.
WHEN I LOOK AT THIS,
I'M THINKING
BED BATH & BEYOND,
I'M THINKING TARGET,
WALMART --
THOSE KIND OF PLACES.
NOPE, NOT ME. QVC.
DAYMOND, YOU THINK THAT THIS
COULD WORK FOR PROMOTIONS?
John: I'M KILLING IT
WITH THE 180 CUP.
THAT'S THE ONE YOU TAKE
THE SHOT OUT OF THE BOTTOM --
THE -- THE RED CUP.
IT'S IN PARTY CITY.
IT MATCHES
WHAT I'M ALREADY DOING,
AND I HAVE
A PROMOTIONAL COMPANY.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
WHOA.
SO, YOU DON'T HAVE ANY SALES,
BASICALLY -- VERY LITTLE SALES.
BUT I WILL OFFER YOU
THE $50,000 --
40%.
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I'M GONNA
HAVE TO DRIVE THIS WHOLE THING.
ZONK, YOU GOT TO TAKE
THE DEAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OFFER.
DAYMOND, ARE YOU INTERESTED
IN TALKING?
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec:
ZONK IS ON A MISSION!
ZONK! YOU'RE GONNA LEAVE
WITH THAT NAME!
I LOVE BOTH --
I LOVE BOTH OF THESE GUYS.
I'LL GO $50,000 FOR 40%,
JUST TO STICK IT TO LORI.
I GOT TO GET TO WORK
ON THIS AND --
BUT I HAVE THE MATCHING PRODUCT,
AND I'M ALREADY SELLING IT.
YOU HAVE THE MATCHING PRODUCT.
YOU HAVE ME. I'LL PEDDLE IT.
THE INTEREST IS THERE.
DO SOMETHING, MAN!
I'M WILLING TO GO TO 30%
IF ONE OF YOU GUYS
CAN MEET ME AT 30%.
ONE OF YOU PUT ZONK
OUT OF HIS PAIN.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT, WHEN THEY SEE
THIS PRODUCT, THEY GO NUTS.
IT'S FUNNY.
IT'S NOT POO-POO.
LORI.
IT'S POO-POO ON A STICK.
I DON'T THINK
I AM NOT LISTENING TO KEVIN,
AND I'M NOT CALLING YOU ZONK.
I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $50,000,
30%, CONTINGENT ON THAT I GET
EITHER BED BATH & BEYOND
OR WALMART OR TARGET --
ONE OF THOSE --
TO GIVE ME
A PURCHASE ORDER.
KEVIN, I'LL GIVE YOU A MILLION
TO ORDER FROM WALMART.
KEVIN, KEVIN, I'M NOT GIVING YOU
A CONTINGENCY, RIGHT?
I HAVE A LICENSING FIRM.
I HAVE TO PAY PEOPLE.
THAT WILL NOT BE YOUR PROBLEM,
ALL RIGHT?
AND THEN WHEN WE HAVE TO GO
AND GET LICENSES,
A LOT OF MY PERCENTAGE
GETS CHEWED DOWN,
SO I HAVE TO STAY AT THAT.
CAN YOU MEET ME AT 35%?
I'LL DO THIS RIGHT NOW.
DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
KEVIN! WELCOME BACK!
I LIKE ZONK BETTER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DO LIKE ZONK
BETTER, THOUGH.
Greiner:
CONGRATS, DAYMOND.
CALL IT THE ZONK-A-TRON.
I'LL CHARGE YOU A ROYALTY.
IT'S CALLED THE BevBoy.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TIME.
IT'S BEEN FUN.
Greiner: CONGRATS.
THANKS, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
TAKE THE CHAIR GUY
WITH YOU.
HE'S FOR YOU.
EVERYBODY,
CLOSE THEIR EYES.
OHH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, NASTY!
THANK YOU GUYS.
CONGRATS.
Herjavec:
WOW. DAYMOND.
I JUST WANTED TO
STICK IT TO YOU.
WELL...
BUT I DO LIKE IT.
I HAD TO FIGHT
FOR THAT ONE.
Waltermire:
I JUST WALKED OUT OF THE TANK.
I JUST GOT A DEAL.
GUESS WHO'S PARTYING TONIGHT.
[ CHUGGING ]
I WILL SHOW THIS
TO THE CONFRéRIE
AT OUR NEXT
CHAPTER MEETING.
NO QUESTION.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A PRODUCT
DESIGNED TO MAKE EATING FUN.
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS ]
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS BOBBIE RHOADS,
FROM WESTPORT, CONNECTICUT.
I AM ASKING FOR $75,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 20% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY, FunBites.
AT FunBites,
WE MAKE FOOD FUN.
DID YOU KNOW THERE ARE
OVER 10 MILLION PICKY-EATER KIDS
IN THE U.S. ALONE?
WELL, THE BIG FOOD COMPANIES
HAVE FIGURED OUT
HOW TO ENTICE THESE KIDS
TO EAT THEIR SUGARY,
COLORFUL SNACKS
IN FUN-SHAPED
NOT-SO-HEALTHY NUGGETS.
WELL, THIS MOM SAYS,
"MOVE OVER, JUNK FOOD.
LET'S MAKE HEALTHY FOOD
MORE FUN."
STUDIES SHOW IF YOU ALLOW YOUR
KIDS TO PLAY WITH THEIR FOOD
AND YOU CUT IT
INTO BITE-SIZE FUN SHAPES,
THEY WILL TRY NEW FOODS
AND EAT HEALTHIER.
I HAVE WITH ME SOME SAMPLES
OF FunBites,
AS WELL AS SOME FUN
FOOD CREATIONS FOR YOU.
THANKS, BOBBIE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THIS ONE?
OKAY, GREAT. THANKS.
SPACEMAN!
NICE HOW IT POPS OUT,
THOUGH. LOOK.
NOW, WOULD ANY OF YOU
LIKE TO GIVE FunBites A TRY?
I'LL DO IT. I'M A CHEF.
COME ON UP.
OKAY, BOBBIE,
WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
OKAY, SO, FIRST,
STEP ONE, REMOVE THE POPPER TOP
AND PLACE TO THE SIDE.
OKAY.
AND PLACE IT
ON THE FOOD --
FIRMLY BACK AND FORTH
FIVE TO SIX TIMES
TO CUT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE FOOD.
KEVIN, WHAT IS THAT?
CHEESE?
NO, I'M DOING A, UH, CAKE
THAT I MADE EARLIER, PREVIOUSLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEN YOU INSERT
THE POPPER TOP.
OKAY.
AND YOU POP...OUT
THE BITE-SIZE PIECES.
WOW.
THAT'S VERY SIMPLE.
Greiner: SO, HOW MANY
DIFFERENT SHAPES ARE THERE?
SO, WE HAVE, UM, THE SQUARES,
HEARTS, AND TRIANGLES.
I JUST WANT TO SEE IF THIS WORKS
THROUGH THE WAFFLE.
YEAH.
OKAY.
SO, DOWN?
YEP.
ROCK IT, ROCK IT.
THEN YOU ROCK
BACK AND FORTH
FIVE TO SIX TIMES.
KEEP GOING, KEEP GOING.
I'M SHOWING HER
HOW TO DO IT.
I'M -- [ CHUCKLES ]
I'M NOT DONE YET.
OH, YOU DIDN'T --
YEAH.
YEAH, YOU SCREWED
THAT UP.
OH, LORI!
NO WAY.
ALTHOUGH
THERE'S STILL SOME --
YOU MESSED IT UP.
NO, SHE'S GOOD.
SHE'S GOOD.
SHE'S NOT A CHEF.
OF COURSE.
I'M NOT A CHEF.
O'Leary:
ALL RIGHT, BOBBIE.
YES.
YOU GOT ANY SALES?
YES, UM, SO WE HAVE
ALMOST $400,000 IN SALES
IN UNDER THREE YEARS.
WHAT ABOUT
THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
UM, THE LAST 12 MONTHS --
$150,000.
IN THE -- IN THE LAST, UH,
THREE MONTHS, $40,000.
OKAY, WHERE ARE YOU
SELLING THIS?
UM, SO WE'RE IN
ABOUT 50 WEBSITES,
AND WE JUST APPROVED
TO BE ON TARGET.
I JUST CAME BACK
FROM A TRADE SHOW.
IN FACT, ALL THE WAY
FROM TOYS"R"US TO NORDSTROM
IS INTERESTED IN US.
BUT, BOBBIE, YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR THREE YEARS.
I'M SURE YOU'VE HAD INTEREST
FROM A LOT OF OTHER BIG --
BIG-BOX RETAILERS
IN THE PAST.
WHY DO YOU THINK
YOU HAVEN'T GROWN MORE?
WELL, I DID -- I DID ACTUALLY
GET INTO, UH, KOHL'S
AND BED BATH & BEYOND
RIGHT OUT OF THE --
YOU KNOW, THE GATE.
IT WAS LIKE 18 MONTHS IN.
AND WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT WAS THE SELL-THROUGH LIKE?
SO, WHAT HAPPENED WAS,
I PULLED TOGETHER A PACKAGE,
AND IT WAS A CLAMSHELL --
YOU KNOW, JUST QUICKLY.
WHEN IT WENT IN STORES,
IT JUST WASN'T SELLING.
CAN WE SEE
YOUR NEW PACKAGING?
YEAH, HERE'S
THE NEW PACKAGING.
YEAH, AND, UH -- AND WHERE
ARE YOU MAKING THIS?
WE MAKE IT IN CONNECTICUT.
AND HOW MUCH
DOES IT COST YOU TO MAKE,
AND WHAT
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
I LIKE THE PACKAGING.
COSTS ME $1.72.
$1.72?
$1.72.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL IT FOR, BOBBIE?
WELL, WHOLESALE IS $6.
RETAIL IS $12.99.
WOW.
GREAT.
GOOD MARGINS.
GO BACK TO THE RETAILS
THAT BROUGHT YOU IN,
THE ONES THAT DIST--
STOPPED SELLING.
ARE THEY GONNA TAKE IT BACK
IN WITH THE NEW PACKAGING?
YEAH.
I JUST GOT THIS PACKAGING
IN THE LAST SIX WEEKS.
UM, KOHL'S LOVES IT.
AND INTERESTING ENOUGH --
THEY HAD US IN THE BABY SECTION.
THEY WANT TO PUT US
IN THE KITCHEN SECTION NOW.
INTERESTING.
SO THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE
YOU BACK IN,
GIVE YOU ANOTHER CHANCE...
RIGHT.
...AND PUT YOU
INTO THAT SECTION.
SO, I'M JUST CURIOUS,
YOU KNOW --
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT?
YEAH.
SO, I JUST GOT
OUR UTILITY PATENT --
FOR CUTTING FOOD
INTO SMALL PIECES?
INTO ANY KIND OF SHAPES.
BOBBIE, HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH IT?
SO, I WENT
TO CARNEGIE MELLON
IN PITTSBURGH.
PITTSBURGH.
THEN AFTER THAT,
I WENT AND WORKED FOR REVLON
FOR EIGHT,
UH -- EIGHT YEARS.
I WAS THE YOUNGEST VP
OF MARKETING AT 32 YEARS OLD.
WOW.
I RAN 40% OF THEIR BUSINESS.
SO, THEN I DECIDED
TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME OFF
WITH MY KIDS,
AND I HAD SUPER-PICKY EATERS.
AND I REALIZED
THAT IF I MADE THE FOOD FUN
AND CREATED LITTLE SHAPES,
THAT THEY WOULD TRY NEW THINGS
AND EAT HEALTHIER.
BOBBIE, JUST ON THE TOPIC
OF KIDS BEING PICKY EATERS --
AND, YOU KNOW, MY WIFE
EXPERIENCED THE SAME THING
WITH OUR KIDS --
I ASKED HER ONE DAY,
"YOU KNOW, WHY DON'T WE
JUST LET THEM STARVE, AND WE'LL
SEE WHEN THEY ACTUALLY --
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS."
JUST SAYING.
YEAH, BUT THE TWO HOURS
OF SCREAMING ISN'T WORTH IT.
John: BOBBIE, UH,
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.
YOU -- YOU TALKED
ABOUT $40,000 IN SALES RECENTLY,
OR...
$40,000 FOR THE THREE MONTHS --
LAST THREE MONTHS.
WHAT DO YOU
ATTRIBUTE THAT TO?
UM, YOU KNOW, WE LAUNCHED
OUR NEXT WEBSITE,
AND, UM, ALSO, WE'RE REALLY BIG
AT BACK-TO-SCHOOL SEASON,
LIKE THE SEASONAL --
WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET AT --
DID YOU INCLUDE THE TRADE SHOW
IN THAT? SORRY, DAYMOND.
I JUST WANTED TO HEAR
HER POINT.
NO, NO.
I JUST CAME
FROM THE TRADE SHOW.
I HAD 25 ORDERS
THAT ARE STILL COMING IN --
SOME OF THEM LARGER,
SOME OF THEM SMALLER.
BUT REALLY, THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
THING THAT HAPPENED
TO THE TRADE SHOW IS I HAD
PEOPLE SEEKING ME OUT.
LIKE DISNEY --
I WAS ON MY CORNER BOOTH,
JUST DOING MY SALE.
VERY TOUGH TO GET
INTO DISNEY -- VERY TOUGH.
AND THE DISNEY GUY HOLDS
THE PACKAGING, AND HE SAYS --
HOW DID YOU KNOW HE'S FROM
DISNEY? HE GIVE YOU A CARD?
HE GAVE ME A CARD, AND HE GOES,
"I'M WITH MARVEL COMICS.
"I THINK WE CAN, LIKE,
CHANGE THE PACKAGING
"TO PUT THE MARVEL COMICS GUY
ON THERE
AND KEEP
YOUR WHOLE CHARACTER."
AND HE WAS REALLY SERIOUS?
HE WAS THERE FOR 20 MINUTES.
AND THAT'S WHY I NEED YOU GUYS.
I DON'T KNOW --
BOBBIE, WHAT --
W-W-WHY ARE YOU HERE?
WHY DO YOU NEED THE MONEY?
OKAY, WELL, UM, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE TRIED TO GET ON THIS SHOW
FOR THREE YEARS.
MY DAD IN PITTSBURGH --
YOU MADE IT!
YEAH! I KNOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Cuban: WE'RE DONE HERE.
I THINK WE'RE DONE.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW
I HAVE TAKEN THIS COMPANY AS --
AS FAR AS I CAN GO
AS ONE PERSON.
I WORK 24/7.
I'M THE HARDEST WORKER.
THEY USED TO CALL ME AT REVLON
THE ENERGIZER BUNNY.
[ Voice breaking ]
UH, I JUST --
I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO GET THOSE DOORS OPEN.
ONCE I GET IN, I CAN SELL IT.
I KNOW HOW TO SELL MY PRODUCT,
BUT I NEED YOUR HELP.
CONGRATULATIONS ON GETTING HERE,
FIRST OF ALL.
THANK YOU.
I'M, LIKE, ABOUT TO CRY,
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE HERE.
I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE MONEY?
WHAT AM I GONNA DO
YOU KNOW, I COULD DO ANYTHING
WITH THE MONEY,
BUT WHAT I'M MOSTLY ASKING FOR
IS FOR YOU GUYS
TO HELP ME OPEN UP THE DOORS
TO GET INTO THE BIG-BOX
RETAILERS AND EXPLORE THE P--
YOU KNOW,
POTENTIAL OF LICENSING.
AND ADDITIONALLY, UM, I RECENTLY
FOUND THAT WE HAVE A BIG NICHE
WITH THE SPECIAL-NEEDS
MARKET.
WE JUST GOT
THE AblePlay AWARD,
WHICH IS FOR CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM.
AND THE AUTISTIC KIDS
LOVE THE SQUARES
BECAUSE THE SQUARES ARE VERY
NEAT, ORGANIZED, AND SIMPLE.
SO, UM, THAT'S A WHOLE MARKET
THAT I'M JUST BEGINNING
TO EXPLORE.
OH, YEAH, I CAN SEE THAT.
L-LOOK, BOBBIE, I-I DON'T SEE
WORLD DOMINATION
OF, UH,
FOOD-SLICING DEVICES,
AND FRANKLY, I SAY TO A CHILD
THAT WON'T EAT FOOD,
"OKAY, DON'T EAT."
OHH, MAN! HOW DID YOUR KIDS
TURN OUT NORMAL, KEVIN?
SO YOU'RE SAYING
'CAUSE THEY'RE SO STARVING,
THEY'RE JUST GONNA EAT
WHATEVER'S SITTING THERE?
THEY'LL EAT IT.
BOBBIE, I'M OUT.
BOBBIE, LET ME --
LET ME CLEAR THINGS A LITTLE BIT
AND TELL YOU WHERE I'M AT.
UH, I WAS A STAY-AT-HOME DAD
FOR THREE YEARS,
AND I-I AGREE WITH YOU.
I USED TO TAKE A KNIFE
AND USED TO DRIVE MY WIFE NUTS
'CAUSE EVERY MEAL WE HAD
WAS CUT UP INTO FUNNY SHAPES.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
KIDS WILL EAT IT IF IT'S FUN.
BUT I-I-I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS
WHEN THE ALTERNATIVE
IS SIMPLY TAKING A KNIFE
AND CUTTING THE FOOD.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, THREE SHARKS ARE LEFT.
SO, I'M SOMEONE
INTERESTED IN THIS,
AND I THINK THE THINGS
THAT INTEREST ME
IS, UH, THE LICENSING.
WE KNOW THE MARVEL GUY
FAIRLY WELL.
AND I CAN GET YOU
THE OTHER LICENSES.
UM, SO I'LL MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
SO THE OFFER WILL BE
$100,000 FOR 30%.
OOH. I THINK YOU
ONLY ASKED FOR $75,000.
MORE MONEY
AND GREATER EQUITY.
I JUST WANT A LITTLE BIT MORE
EQUITY SO WE CAN --
YOU KNOW,
I-IT'S WORTH OUR TIME.
UM, 'CAUSE I KNOW
I'M GONNA HAVE TO GO OUT THERE
FOR ALL THESE LICENSES,
AND IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME.
O'Leary:
SO, LORI, DAYMOND HAS THROWN
A TRIANGULAR PIECE OF CHEESE
IN YOUR FACE
WITH THAT OFFER.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
[ LAUGHS ]
LORI, IT ALSO WOULD BE
A GREAT QVC PRODUCT.
YOU KNOW, WE COULD --
PEOPLE --
WELL, YOU KNOW,
AS I'M THINKING ABOUT IT,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A SPECIAL
SECTION IN BED BATH & BEYOND.
I'M GLAD I GAVE YOU
THAT CONTACT.
I HAVE MY PRODUCTS --
WE ALL HAVE SPECIAL SECTIONS
IN BED BATH & BEYOND.
BOBBIE,
I MADE YOU AN OFFER.
DAYMOND,
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
CAN I JUST HEAR
THE OTHER OFFERS?
IT TOOK ME
SO LONG TO GET HERE,
I JUST WANT TO HEAR
ALL THE OFFERS.
SO, GUESS WHAT TIME IT IS?
WHAT TIME IS IT?
IT'S DEAL TIME.
[ DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS ]
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
BOBBIE HAS AN OFFER FROM DAYMOND
FOR HER FOOD-CUTTING PRODUCT,
FunBites,
BUT LORI ALSO SEEMS INTERESTED.
GUESS WHAT TIME IT IS.
WHAT TIME IS IT?
IT'S DEAL TIME, SO...
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO, I'M THINKING HERE.
I HAVE ALL THE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE STORES --
THE BED BATH, THE buybuy BABY,
THE TOYS"R"US -- ALL OF THAT.
I BELIEVE THE RETAIL PLAY
IS IMPORTANT FOR YOU.
MM-HMM.
I THINK YOU NEED TO
GET IT OUT THERE,
LIKE, IN ALL THOSE LOCATIONS
AND DO YOUR WEBSITE.
MM-HMM.
I MEAN, I THINK
YOU NEED TO BE BOTH.
I LIKE TO BLITZ
THE MARKET.
RIGHT.
AND THE OFFER IS...
THE OFFER IS $75,000...
MM-HMM.
...FOR 25% EQUITY.
OOH!
YOU KNOW, FOR ME --
LORI, HOW MANY PRODUCTS
HAVE YOU LICENSED?
DAYMOND --
LORI, LISTEN --
I HAVE ACTUALLY LICENSED...
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
...FIVE PRODUCTS.
JUST SUMMARIZE.
IF YOU WANT TO DO LICENSING
AND YOU WANT ALL THOSE BRANDS,
I AM THE ONE TO DO IT.
BUT I CAN LICENSE, TOO.
I'VE ALREADY DONE SIX LICENSES
ON THIS SHOW.
LISTEN, SHE HAS NO ANSWER
IN REGARDS TO LICENSING
'CAUSE IT'S ZERO.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO?
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $100,000.
OKAY, LET'S TALK, BOBBIE.
I'LL ACTUALLY MATCH HERS.
HERE'S MARK'S OFFER.
HERE'S MARK'S OFFER COMING.
I'M GONNA DO $100,000 NOW
FOR 25%.
WHOA! HANG ON. DAYMOND,
DID YOU CHANGE YOUR OFFER?
I'D LIKE YOU
TO TAKE MY OFFER NOW
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WANT TO PARTNER
WITH ME.
YES.
SO IF YOU WANT
TO PARTNER WITH ME,
I'D LIKE YOU TO SAY YES
RIGHT NOW.
LORI...I'LL DO IT.
YEAH!
YAY!
ALL RIGHT!
WAY TO GO, BOBBIE!
WHOO-HOO!
CRAP.
BOBBIE.
IT'S HER MISTAKE.
WOW. LOOK AT THAT.
YOU'RE WONDERFUL.
I'M SO HAPPY.
BOBBIE,
YOU MADE THE RIGHT CALL.
AND WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THIS HUGE.
HUGE!
YEAH.
YOU MADE THE RIGHT CALL.
BOBBIE, YOU MADE A MISTAKE.
NO, YOU DIDN'T.
YOU KNOW WHY, BOBBIE?
LOOK --
YOU GOT A GOOD PARTNER.
I'M NOT GONNA SAY ANYTHING BAD
ABOUT LORI.
WE'VE PARTNERED IN DEALS.
SHE DOES THINGS WELL, RIGHT?
BUT SOMETIMES THERE'S
A BENEFIT TO LISTENING.
AND ACTUALLY, IT'S NOT TOO LATE
TO CHANGE YOUR MIND.
BOBBIE, YOU HAVE A CHANCE
TO DO SOMETHING UNIQUE
AND A FIRST IN THE TANK --
THROW LORI UNDER THE BUS
WITH THE RISK OF NOT YET
HAVING HEARD MARK'S OFFER.
DON'T DO IT, BOBBIE.
THROW HER UNDER THE BUS!
I LOVE MARK. YOU KNOW,
HE'S FROM THE BURGH, TOO.
AND -- AND -- AND I WISH
I WOULD'VE HEARD HIS OFFER.
BUT TO BE HONEST, I KNOW LORI'S
THE RIGHT PARTNER FOR ME.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW SHE CAN
FIX THE PACKAGING.
Greiner: THANK YOU, BOBBIE.
O'Leary:
THROW HER UNDER THE BUS!
I KNOW YOU'RE A PERSON
OF INTEGRITY, BOBBIE.
WOULD YOU WANT TO
BRING MARK IN?
NO.
OH!
OKAY, ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
I JUST HAVE TO GIVE --
O'Leary:
BOBBIE, BEFORE YOU LEAVE --
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR HIM.
GOOD LUCK, BOBBIE.
Greiner:
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, GUYS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
BYE.
UNDER THE BUS!
I REALLY THOUGHT
SHE WAS GONNA GO FOR IT.
I THOUGHT YOU HAD HER.
I'M SO EXCITED.
IT WAS EXACTLY WHO I WANTED
AND A PERFECT DEAL FOR ME.